sie wissen alle wer das ist das ist
natürlich aristoteles natürlich bleibt
netz und er hat neue abhandlung über den
menschlichen verstand geschrieben und in
diesen abhandlungen kommentiert er
kritisch schon luxury die
handlungsfreiheit ein paar fragen wie
verhalten sich determinismus und
freiheit nach leibnitz zueinander
das ist eine frage bleibt es vertritt ja
eine art fan kompatibel ist muss er sagt
freiheit und die termin und
determination widersprechen sich nicht
sondern freiheit bedeutet gerade auf
eine bestimmte weise der terminiert sein
das ist seine these welche verschiedenen
arten von freiheit unterscheidet
leibnitz dass da habe man dinge das
zitat das hat mit letzten sitzung schon
kurz an gelesen dass wir auch noch ein
bisschen genauer behandelt und dann wie
kritisiert leibnitz den locken
freiheitsbegriff es geht ihm vor allem
um die frage ob wir nicht noch unser
wollen wollen können wir uns wirklich
auf unseren willen beziehen können das
hatte ja lok für unnötig erklärt block
hat ihre mehr oder weniger gesagt wenn
wir einmal einen willen haben dann
brauchen wir nicht mit den willen zu
hinterfragen sind brauchen wir nur noch
uns darum kümmern dass wir diesen willen
in eine handlung übersetzen dann sind
wir frei wenn wir diesen will den wir
jetzt mal haben auch realisieren können
den wählern selbst nochmal zu wollen um
frei zu sein sagt bleibt es ist lockt
ist unnötig das führt in so ein regress
und das hat uns wieder an harry
frankfurt genau das sind so die fragen
die wir jetzt lesen wollen und jetzt
ändern und jetzt komme ich noch auf
dieses längere tat zu sprechen also
leibnitz sagt der ausdruck freiheit ist
sehr zweideutig es gibt eine rechtlich
und eine tatsächliche freiheit
im sinne des rechts ist ein sklave nicht
frei ein untertan ist es nicht völlig
aber ein armer ist ebenso frei wie ein
reicher
jetzt wollen wir uns das mal hier so ein
bisschen grafisch veranschaulichen dass
wir hier mal so ein bisschen überblick
bekommen
also wir haben jetzt hier den begriff
der freiheit so und jetzt sagt er hier
mal ist zweideutig es gibt eine
rechtliche alle tatsächlich freiheit
nicht und tatsächlich beim rechtlichen
wie verhält sich da das ist ihr so was
wie zu einem ja eher ein sozialer
begriff wo ihm bestimmte grundrechte
nicht dem der person den menschen
gegeben werden als wären es klar wir
untertan und arme
an
also sklave untertan ist nicht so frei
und ein armer ist schreier als ein
untertan und ein reicher ist natürlich
genauso frei würde jetzt leide nicht
sagen wie ein armer weil er nicht
rechtlich begrenzt ist
also hat dieselben rechte letztendlich
da dieselben garantierten rechte zum
beispiel jetzt bin ich mir bei uns wir
haben jetzt hier in deutschland meines
wissens keine sklaven mehr also
zumindest nicht offiziell
das mag natürlich arbeitsplatten geben
aber rechtlich haben wir als keine
sklaven hier und wir haben auch
eigentlich keine untertanen mehr als
sklaven hatten wir vielleicht ich weiß
nicht von deutschland vielleicht vor 300
jahren noch ein bisschen unter tage
hatten wir noch bis vor 200 jahren
und natürlich kann man heute immer noch
sagen dass jemand untertan ist einem
brand einer anderen person aber das ist
dann eher so metaphorisch die person hat
dieselben rechte man ist vielleicht
angestellten ist warum hat dieselben
rechte und auf rechtlicher in
rechtlicher hinsicht was unsere
grundrechte anbelangt ist eben ein armer
genauso rechtlich frei wie ein reicher
und jetzt das ist mehr oder weniger
trivial das ist einfach nur seine so
eine zuordnung von rechten
also du darfst das nicht per gesetz du
darfst es
und jetzt kommt die tatsächliche
freiheit und die ist spannend da weil
die besteht entweder vehlitz leider
zeigten dem vermögen das zu tun was man
will oder in dem vermögen des richtigen
wollen selbst und das kann man jetzt
unterscheiden in handlungsfreiheit das
ist das tun können was man will und in
willensfreiheit
als er bestimmt die willensfreiheit als
das vermögen des richtigen wollens
selbst also das wollen selbst ist noch
ist gegenstand der betrachtung
sie sprechen hier von der freiheit des
handelns und diese hat ihre gerade in
verschiedenheit im allgemeinen ist
derjenige welcher mehr mittel hat freie
das zu tun was er will aber im
besonderen bezieht man die freiheit auf
den gebrauch derjenigen dinge die
gewöhnlichen unsere gewalt sind also vor
allem auf den freien gebrauch unseres
körpers also ein reicher wäre es der
handlungsfreiheit freier als ein armer
weil er mehr möglichkeiten hat mehr geld
kann mehr sein es mir wünsche oder mehr
willens strömungen realisieren an die
handlung umsetzen ich will jetzt auf den
mond fliegen kann ein reicher eine
reiche person kann das tatsächlich tun
sie ist in ihrer handlungsfreiheit nicht
eingeschränkt für eine arme person wäre
das auf den mond fliegen nur ein wunsch
weil sie nicht die mittel dazu besitzt
diesen wunsch zu einem willen werden zu
lassen nicht handlungswillig seine
reiche person hat die mittel ihre ihre
wünsche zum willen verhandlungsleiter
den willen werden lassen zu können
das ist praktisch graduell also der
mittel hat ist freier in seiner
handlungsfreiheit werden in diesem sinne
sind kerker und krankheiten in dem sie
uns verhindern unseren körpern unsere
gegen diejenigen bewegung zu geben die
wir hingegen wollen und gewöhnlich geben
können beschränkungen unserer freiheit
und man sagt dass ein gefangener nicht
frei sei und ein gelähmter keine freien
gebrauch seiner kinder habe
das ist natürlich alles jetzt noch
handlungsfreiheit und jetzt gehör weiter
die freiheit des wollens wird
gleichfalls um zwei verschiedene
bedeutung genommen und in der einen
setzt man sie der unvollkommenheit oder
sklaverei des geistes entgegen in der
der geist und einem zwang und einer
hemmung wenngleich diese von ihnen
stammen handelt wie dies bei den
leidenschaften der fall ist
also wie sollte man jetzt das
beschreiben als er bildet hier die
verhältnissen wollen noch mal
unterschreiben
wie soll man das jetzt nicht was ist das
jetzt vom fall
das ist die freiheit von der
unvollkommenheit unter sklaverei des
geistes
ja
also wie könnte man das dann nennen
freiheit von geistigen zwingen so was
die frage ist halt vielleicht
selbstkontrolle vielleicht sogar
selbstkontrolle kunden würden sie sagen
kontrolle willens kontrolle dass man
nicht den leidenschaften unterliegt
willens kontrolle oder
freiheit der vernunft kommen auch noch
drauf schreiben uns doch einfach mal ein
wenn wir mal ein bisschen weiter lesen
als interessant ist jetzt diese
hemmungen stammen von innen in dem zitat
was wir vorhatten
denken sie mal hier angefangen selbst
ein gelähmter da wäre dann die
einschränkung von außen als unser körper
macht nicht mehr mit oder wir sind in
einem gefängnis geworfen das ist eine
äußere beschränkungen zur freiheit und
jetzt geht es hierbei der freiheit des
wollens geht es also geht es um das
innere dass die handlungsfreiheit
bezieht ihr so das verhältnis des
willens zur äußeren umständen werden wir
von außen sei es auch durch unsere
körperhöhle daran gehindert unseren
willen zu einer handlung zu realisieren
das betrifft also die handlungs vater
geht es ihrem äußere einschränkungen und
bei der willensfreiheit geht zum innere
einschränkungen und jetzt kann natürlich
eine innere einschränkung können unsere
leidenschaften sein
in einer anderen bedeutung sagt jetzt
aber lebens bildet die freiheit
gegensatz zur notwendigkeit das könnte
man vielleicht eine metaphysische
freiheit nennen
im gegensatz zur notwendigkeit ersteren
szene jetzt weiterlesen sagten die
historiker dass der weise allein frei
sei
und in der tat ist der geist wenn er von
einer großen leidenschaft in anspruch
genommen ist nicht frei wenn man kann
als dann nicht in der richtigen weise
das heißt wie der nötigen überlegung
wollen
also dann können wir das noch mal
vielleicht nimmt freiheit der überlegung
wie würden sie denn freiheit des
verstandes vernunft vielleicht kann man
auch sagen freiheit der überlegung
erstmal nach vernunft bringt dahin
begriff der überlegung als man kann auf
die richtige weise wollen und das ist
eben wiederbelegung wir können auch
sagen mit dem verstand der vernunft ja
essen
die abwesenheit
er kommt jetzt später noch auf die
freiheit des geistes und das ist noch
eine andere freiheit das ist die
freiheit die gegen die notwendigkeit
jetzt gerichtet ist deswegen gut er sagt
jetzt hier in diesem sinne ist gott
allein vollkommen frei weil gott eben
keine leidenschaften in sich hat kann
inneren hemmungen die erschaffenen geist
aber sind nur in dem maße frei als über
die leidenschaften haben sind und diese
freiheit betrifft eigentlich unseren
verstand allem könnte man vielleicht
doch sagen freiheit des verstandene
freiheit des verstandes wir gegen
gegenüber den verneigungen aber dass das
ist praktisch gegen gegen leidenschaften
und die die verhandlungsfreiheit ist
freiheit gegenüber dem äußeren zwang das
praktisch ihnen das hier betrifft das
innere die leidenschaften sind auch
innere phänomen als es die überlegung
hat es kein vernünftig sein
wir können uns nach vernünftigen
kriterien richten und dadurch unsere
leidenschaften eben ein kontrollieren
und jetzt gesagt dass die freiheit des
geistes aber welche der notwendigkeit
entgegengesetzt ist betrifft bloß den
willen und zwar sofern er sich vom
vorstand unterscheidet sie ist dasjenige
was man 3 wilke nennt womit gemeint sein
soll dass der willensakt trotzdem
stärker sind gründen oder motiven die
der verstand den willen vorhält
nichtsdestoweniger immer zufällig bleibt
und keine absolute und sozusagen
metaphysische notwendigkeit besitzt in
diesem sinne pflege ich zu sagen dass
der verstand den willen je nach den
vorherrschenden perzeption und gründen
zwar auf sichere und fehlbare art
bestimmen kann dass er ihn aber
nichtsdestoweniger nur zu einer
entscheidung geneigt macht ohne ihn zu
nötigen
also wir müssen jetzt diese letzte noch
verbleibende freiheit nennen
er hat er den begriff gebracht das ist
die freiheit des
sie hat die freiheit des verstandes
analysiert und jetzt kommt er hier die
freiheit des geistes also man darf jetzt
geist und verstand nicht verwechseln
das ist noch verschieden also freiheit
des geistes
und die ist jetzt gegen was gerichtet
nicht mehr gegen die die leidenschaft
sondern gegen was ist jetzt gerichtet
die freiheit des geistes
er denkt also immer die freiheit im
sinne einer negativen freiheit auch ne
also die der freiheit das der handlung
ist gegenüber äußeren zwang frei von
äußeren zwang die freiheit des
verstandes ist die freiheit von den
leidenschaften die jetzt als etwas
inneres gedacht werden und was jetzt die
freiheit des geistes für was die eine
freiheit wie vor ist die frau mit ihrem
text schon
genau das ist richtig freiheit von dem
verstand oder sie haben genau das auch
noch der freiheit von der notwendigkeit
also schreibt
sie sehen sofort dass leidenschaft und
notwendigkeit auf einer ganz anderen
ebene liegen also bei des geistes
freiheit des geistes ist die freiheit
gegenüber der notwendigkeit als er will
damit sagen freiheit des wollens kann
dann eingeschränkt oder gefährdet sein
wenn wir es entweder mit leidenschaften
zu tun haben also wenn in unserem
inneren gespalten sind ist ein problem
der willensfreiheit klassischerweise und
auch wenn wir es mit notwendigkeit zu
tun haben mein notwendigkeit für
leibnitz freiheit kategorisch
ausschließt notwendigkeit ist für
leibnitz etwas was uns keine
alternativen möglichkeiten mehr
eröffnete notwendigkeit schränkt uns auf
eine linie ein ja
guter bruder punkt also er unterscheidet
die notwendigkeit von dem determinismus
das ist ein wichtiger punkt als er sagt
wir können frei sein wenn wir
determiniert sind die termination ist
schwächer zu verstehen als notwendigkeit
notwendigkeit ist der völlige ausschluss
alternative möglichkeiten
also ich würde das jetzt nicht im sinne
des kausalen beeinflusst seines denkens
haushalt beeinflusst zu sein ist für
leibnitz eine form der determination und
der termination ist für leibnitz
prinzipiell mit freiheit des willens
kompatibel
er bringt jetzt noch die gründe dafür
dezember zur notwendigkeit bedeutet nur
der ausschluss alternativen
möglichkeiten es gibt nur eine
möglichkeit sie können darüber nicht
mehr verfügen wir können uns selbst
nicht bestimmen
zum einen oder zum anderen so wir müssen
die eine möglichkeit nehmen sie steht
nicht und unserer gewalt zu sagen das
ist die metaphysische notwendigkeit die
es zu vermeiden gibt und die hat er
jetzt freiheit des geistes
spannend war das geist man ja das ist
eine komplett sagte sie diese freiheit
des geistes ist das hier geht was man
die freie willkür nennt womit gemeint
sein soll dass ich den willensakt trotz
der stärksten gründe oder motive die der
verstand den willen vorhält
nichtsdestoweniger immer zufällig bleibt
und keine absolute und sozusagen
metaphysische notwendigkeit sitzt also
damit ist gemeint metaphysische
notwendigkeit ist es gibt keine
alternative möglichkeit freiheit dagegen
bedeutet für leibnitz dass die
entscheidung immer kontingent ist
kontingent heißt sie hätte auch anders
sein können
sie musste nichts was sein es gibt
alternative möglichkeiten kontingent
bedeutet nicht notwendig und nicht
unmöglich so einfach möglich
in diesem sinne pflege ich zu sagen dass
der verstand den willen je nach den
vorherrschenden perzeption und gründen
zwar auf sicher unfehlbare watt
bestimmen kann
da sind aber nichtsdestoweniger nutzer
seiner entscheidung gemacht ohne ihn zu
nötig hier geht es wieder wie bei thomas
von aquin um die frage und auch bei
block wie sich wille und verstand
zueinander verhalten
das ist die spannende frage und jetzt
eben leibnitz wille und verstand dürfen
sich nicht so zueinander verhalten dass
der wille in anführungsstrichen jetzt
das tool 0 was der verstand als gut
erkennen das ist das notwendigerweise
tun muss das also dem verstand
untergeordnet ist dass er ihn
folge leiste automatisch das verhältnis
von wille und verstand ist ein
kontingentes es ist nur das verhältnis
der bestimmung aber nicht das verhältnis
der notwendigkeit dass wir wissen wir
schon mal die notwendigkeit ist mit
freiheit nicht kompatibel determination
schon jetzt müssen wir da mal ein
bisschen genauer darauf eingehen was
treibt uns damit genau meint also das
ist jetzt die übersichtlich erklärt sie
noch einmal kurz zum überblick
also haben wir freiheit rechtlich ist
trivial uns klar wir haben natürlich
nicht die rechte gilt als nicht allzu
freie
er steht seinem herrn seit seinem herrn
und auf der iss untertal und da kann es
ganz ähnlich untertanen sind zwar keine
sklaven aber sie sind rechtlich nicht so
frei und auf derselben ebene stehen aber
arme und reiche weil sie dieselben
rechtlichen freiheiten genießen sie
dürfen zum beispiel die selben dinge tun
zb durften sklaven nicht heiraten landes
lahm verboten
und wenn ich mich recht erinnere war
sogar so dass untertanen im 18 oder 19
jahrhundert im 18 jedenfalls ich weiß
nicht ob sie nicht heiraten durften ab
und zwar zwei eigentlich völlig
unmöglich für untertan zu heiraten
das wäre natürlich eine rechtliche
unfreiheit was du unsere grundrechte
anbelangt der unterzahl aber ich glaube
sie dürften auch nicht heiraten
viele haben es jedenfalls nicht allein
schon aufgrund der stellung ist es
rechtliche arbeit arm und reich sind ja
eigentlich gleich gestellt und jetzt
gibt es aber die tatsächliche die
betrifft unser handeln
und hier kann man eben sagen
handlungsfreiheit ist die freiheit vor
äußeren zwang sind nicht abhängig von
beschränkungen wir sind nicht in einem
gefängnis an fesselt uns nicht unser
körper ist dass man uns zugänglich wir
haben keine irgendwelche
körperlichen einschränkungen die uns
hindern unseren willen jetzt anhand und
für das die handlungsfreiheit und aber
noch die innere freiheit die betrifft
unseren willen damit das wollen dass die
freiheit des verstandes das ist
sozusagen diese weisheit der historiker
wir können unsere inneren regungen
triebe und was noch immer kontrollieren
also wir sind herr über unseren unsere
leidenschaften
oder gibt es auch die freiheit des
geistes das ist sozusagen eine freiheit
die ihre freiheit gegenüber dem verstand
noch einmal behauptet also dass wir eben
nicht demjenigen notwendigerweise folgen
müssen was unser verstand als gut
erkennt und so verstand zeitlebens macht
uns nur geneigt er inkludiert uns eine
handlung habe er zitiert uns nicht dazu
sonst wären wir ja unfrei gegenüber dem
verstand also das ist die freiheit
letztendlich gegenüber dem verstanden
also der geist reflektiert nochmal auf
den verstand zu sorgen es ist schwierig
vorzustellen das haben wir hier ein paar
weitere zitate
halser und jetzt kommt eine
entscheidende zitat man muss das
notwendige vom zufälligen auch wenn
dieses bestimmt ist unterscheiden
denn nicht nur sind die zufälligen
wahrheiten selbst nicht notwendig sind
auch ihre verknüpfungen haben nicht
immer eine absolute notwendigkeit
ohne zweifel besteht ein unterschied
ihnen der bestimmung der konsequenzen im
bereich des notwendigen und im bereich
des zufälligen die geometrischen und
metaphysischen konsequenzen enthalten
eine nötigung die physischen und
moralischen aber machen nur geneigt ohne
zu nötigen
wilkinson es ist er hat am französisch
geschrieben
das ist ursprünglich französische
sprache verfasst worden jetzt müssen wir
uns darüber ein bisschen klarer werden
wie verstehen sie jetzt die
unterscheidung von notwendigen und zu
verlegen was ist denn eine tatsachen
wahrheit
auf geht's nämlich kommt nämlich
leibnitz zu sprechen was in zufälliger
wahrheiten zufällige wahrheiten
was ist eine zufällige wahrheit
unterscheidet sich von einer notwendigen
wahrheit geben sie dann am beispiel von
die zufällige wahrheit ja genau wurde
dass sie gerade sich melden das dass sie
sich gerade gewöhnt haben dass eine
zufällige wahrheit warum ist die
wahrheit zufällig genau also in
mathematischen verhältnissen ist das
ergebnis reduzierbar ja ich kann also
aus stimmten gegebenen prämissen oder
mathematischen aktionen etwas beliebig
entferntes notwendigerweise herleiten
und so denken es auch viele wenn sie zum
beispiel dass konsequenz argument von
beta von ihnen wagen da haben sie ja
hier l&w 0 oder was auch immer folgt wie
pixar diesmal die welt zu einem
beliebigen zustand ja das ist eine
reduktion
das wäre letztendlich nach leibnitz wenn
ich ein recht verstehe eine
metaphysische notwendigkeit dass wir
also
beide termine sind so dass es keine
alternativen möglichkeiten offen stehen
also geometrische notwendigkeiten denken
sie einen satz targo rus sie können c
quadrat ausrechnen wenn sie a quadrat
und bedroht haben
c quadrat ist eben die summe aus beiden
sie können irgendwas einiges ausrechnen
und zwar mit notwendigkeit das ergebnis
bestimmen und metaphysische konsequenzen
wären dann gewissermaßen auch logischer
logische natur haben sie können sie es
gut vorstellbar zur reduktion das ist so
diese notwendigkeit da gibt es gar keine
alternative möglichkeit das ist völlig
sinnlos so was zu fragen das muss so
sein
und zwar aus einer inneren logische
notwendigkeit heraus also die
geometrischen und metaphysischen
konsequenzen enthalten eine nötigung die
physische und moralische machen nur
balkone zu benötigen
ja was ist denn jetzt eine moralische
konsequenz haben sie die
nur eine physische konzipieren
sie haben ein beispiels gebracht was
eine zufällige wahrheit wäre also eine
physische moralische konsequenz müsste
eine zufällige wahrheit sein
haben sie da eine idee was könnte das
sein
ja
für sie hier
mehr
ja also oder dass sie eben in
moralischen kontexten sich bewegen
also es wäre ja zum beispiel dass ich
sagen ich esse kein fleisch weil ich die
überzeugung habe dass das nicht gut ist
da wird jetzt live mit sagen diese
moralische überzeugung dass etwas nicht
gut ist oder so die nötigt uns nicht im
metaphysischen sinn sondern sie ist
letztendlich immer eine zufällige
entscheidung die natürlich trotzdem
bestimmt ist also dürfen sich jetzt
zufällig nicht so vorstellen dass jetzt
da leibnitz denkt wir werfen jetzt eine
münze oder würfeln darüber wie jetzt
unsere entscheidung ausfallen soll
in leibnitz von zufällig spricht meint
er einfach nur dass es nicht notwendig
ist dann ist also auch anders hätte sein
können
das ist so immer der gedanke bei das
kontingent ist das also nicht notwendig
ist und auch alle unsere moralischen
handlungen überzeugung sind nicht
notwendig in diesem sinn
sie haben sie angenommen wir hätten es
auch nicht annehmen können wir haben uns
irgendwann dazu entschieden wir haben
sie uns selbst zu zu recht als endlich
das ist so dieser grundgedanke
hier an
schon
ja das ist guter punkt aber hier ist
jetzt die unterscheidung zwischen geist
und verstand sehr wichtig als man kann
sich das so vorstellen dass der verstand
nach den geometrischen wahrheiten
operiert der verstand ist letztendlich
ein detektive vermögen so könnte man
sich das vorstellen
er verstand ist dasjenige was uns hier
konsequenz argumente ermöglicht die eben
der notwendigkeit gehorchen das
reduzieren des ableiten nach
notwendigkeit und der geist sagt er
hätte freiheit des geistes aber die ist
eben auch eine rationale vermögen aber
es ist ein vermögen war es eben verstand
unterschieden ist insofern es eben immer
noch in seiner determination die grünen
der also gründe gehören hier zum geist
nicht zum verstanden ich immer noch die
kontingenz ermöglicht also man müsste
sich jetzt wenn ich es recht so
verstehen dass verstand sondern dass
detektive vermögen ist einfach das depot
zieren aus vermissen nach notwendigkeit
ok
ja guter einwand wollen sie haben sie
als stuth als kommilitoninnen und
kommilitonen noch eine antwort auf
dieses interessante frage wie würden sie
sich zu dieser frage verhalten
die frage ist jetzt dass wir hatten
jetzt gesagt moralische konsequenzen
sind kontingent jetzt die frage eben
welchem vermögen sind diese moralischen
überlegungen die gründe zuzuordnen und
ich würde eben sagen sie sind nicht den
verstand zuzuordnen sondern eben den
geist als der verstand ist ihr so ein
prinzip uns was gar keine individualität
und flexibilität ermöglicht dem sinne
dass die gründe ich persönlich neige
dazu dass auch damit kann trainer
praktischer vernunft gleichzusetzen also
zu diese kategorische imperativ du
sollst nie wo wir reduzieren dann
letztendlich oder jedenfalls einen
widerspruchs test machen
das ist fast schon so eine art von
notwendigkeit dafür sei der geist ist
eben das was diese moralischen dinge
betrifft im sinne des abwägens von
gründen also die individuelle versagen
der verstand wäre hier wenn ich es recht
verstehe folgende zitat ja so eine
generelle rationalität die uns einfach
vorschreibt was zu tun ist
wo keine spielraum mehr ist und der
geist wäre ebenso wie eine individuelle
ein individueller gebrauch der vernunft
wo wir eben noch mal auf die
rationalität präsiden reflektieren
können und gründe und gegen konnte geben
kann
aber jetzt hatten sie sich gemeldet
also die das ist eine spannende frage
wie man jetzt eben hier den verstand
jetzt verstehen also es ist so dass eben
die stärksten gründe und motive der
verstand gibt die stärksten gründe und
motive da haben sich schon recht der
verstand gibt die habe diese gründe und
motive sind dann in freien individuum
wie wir sie sind nicht notwendig
sie sind kontingent an tun das heißt sie
müssen irgendwie nochmal reflektiert
also es muss dazu noch mal ein
verhältnis geben was sie eben gerade
nicht mehr in die notwendigkeit versetzt
und wenn ich leuten das recht verstehen
wird er entsagen für einen stalker oder
für diese für diese an
für diese freiheit des verstandes ist es
eben allein nur das ausschalten der
inneren hemmungen also letztendlich der
leidenschaften und das reine sich
durchsetzen des verstandes als detektive
sich durchsetzen die gründe die nicht
mehr weiter reflektiert werden also man
kann sie es vielleicht so vorstellen
dass eben in der freiheit des geistes
der verstand noch einmal reflektiert
wird das darauf nochmal bezogen wird und
dass durch diese zusätzliche reflexion
ebene dem verstand die notwendigkeit
genommen wird die mich noch mal drauf
reflektieren und das scheint dann der
geist der geist ist das vermögen weil
sich noch mal auf den verstand reflexiv
bezieht und dadurch die notwendigkeit
eben in eine große determination
verwandelt zum verständnis oder
wäre jetzt falsch größeren die geistige
wurde mit dem 1
aufgeweckt eine andere ins notwendig
dass da in erster linie jetzt nichts
gewöhnliches und mal einstellen
ansonsten zu tun sollen diese mittel
bedienen
der verstand liefert uns sicherlich
gewisse gründe und motive die einsicht
in das war aber es geht jetzt einfach um
die haltung zu diesen gründen und
motiven die uns in uns sich vorfinden
also es geht wenn ich unrecht versteht
stück darum dass die gründe und motive
die der verstand uns vor hält wie er im
vorherigen gesagt hat da die der
verstand den wählern vorhält verstand
dem willen vorhält hier dass die eben zu
eigenen zu eigenen gründen und motiven
werden dass man diese mit adaptieren
muss dass ich sagen kann ich
identifiziere mich mit diesen motiven
und gründen
das wäre letztendlich so was wie science
and order wohl ich mich darauf nochmal
reflexiv bezieht dass ich sie zu meinen
eigenen mache und dass ich dass sie
nicht nur in mir durchschlagen
ihm soll ich mich hindurch laufen dass
ich nicht nur subjekt dieser alle objekt
genau gesehen oder medium durchlaufs
medium des verstandes bin zum dass ich
in meine individualität eben mich zu
diesen gründen verhalte und sie zu
meinen eigenen kunden machen und diese
zu seinen eigenen gründen machen so
interpretiere ich jedenfalls das wäre
eben gerade diese herabstufung von der
notwendigkeit auf die kontingenz die
zufälligkeit hatten sie sich mit
details dadurch dass er immer wieder
über eine überlegung wert
ja so verstehe ich ihn hier genau also
der geist ist halt noch mal ein höheres
vermögen esprit
das ist also französisch esprit und er
sagt auch noch hier
wenn sie mal genau hinschauen sie also
die freiheit des geistes
sie ist dasjenige was man freie willkür
nennt die willkür sie kommt so eine art
von reflexion auch wahl mit ins spiel
als eine reflektierte entscheidung kommt
damit drin
die wahl des willens haben eine höhere
stufe also soll man die noch mal auf die
verstandes motive reflektiert und sie zu
eigenen gründen macht also praktisch
dass man sich davon durch die motive
durchaus beeinflussen lässt aber dass
sie uns nur zu einer entscheidung
geneigt machen ohne uns zu nötigen
also es geht darum dass wir verschiedene
rats vermögen gegeneinander abspielen
und ist er also abklären und der esprit
der geist ist offensichtlich noch ein
höhe stufiges vermögen als der verstand
und darin ist dann die willensfreiheit
im eigentlichen sinne gelegen die eben
und jetzt müssen aber ein bisschen mehr
darauf eingehen die eben diese
kontingents und auch die freiheit und
determination zusammen denken kann also
freiheit ich mache es vielleicht nochmal
ein bisschen ausführlicher nach leibnitz
müssen wir das so denken also frei
treibens ist nach ist ein kompatibel ist
also wir haben freiheit und
determination und nicht notwendigkeit
und kontingenz
freiheit termination kontingents sind
kompatibel
das ist alles das selbe willensfreiheit
und die notwendigkeit wird
ausgeschlossen
die dürfen nicht haben jetzt kann man
natürlich sagen ja das klingt ja alles
ganz toll
natürlich wollen wir alle willens frei
sein wir wollen alle in unserem handeln
bestimmt sein dass es also gegen die in
gegenden indifferent is muss dagegen der
libertarian ist muss wir wollen ganz
klar bestimmt seien durch gründe durch
faktoren und wir wollen nicht das
problem haben dass wir jetzt aus diesem
gleichgewichtszustand wie boogie danzl
denken sie zurück an diesen esel der
zwei genau gleich große heuhaufen vor
seinem kopf hat und der dann ende gar
nicht mehr weiß wie er jetzt sich
entscheiden soll also von oben
betrachtet ist dass der esel ist der
kopf und hier hat er zwei genau gleich
große haufen
wohin jetzt wohin jetzt wir haben gar
kein motiv letztendlich wenn mir genau
differenziert und leibnitz sagt nein wir
brauchen immer noch so eine
determination einen grund zu etwas hin
aber diese situation darf nicht mit
notwendigkeit gleichgesetzt werden
sondern sie muss konsequent sein es
hätte auch ganz anders sein können
das ist jetzt die spannende frage weil
wenn das lebens wirklich gelingt dann
hat er alles was wir für willens bald
einig brauchen um starke sinne aber kein
indifferent ismus wir haben kein
konsequenz argument sondern wir haben
eben das beste aus allen welten und das
müssen wir jetzt mal noch ein bisschen
weiter lesen
ob uns das auch wirklich überzeugen kann
wenn man über die freiheit des willens
oder über die freie willkür spricht so
fragt man nicht ob der mensch tun kann
was er will und ob er in seinem willen
selbst unabhängigkeit besitzt man fragt
nicht ob eine freie füße und hände hat
ist ein ob sein geist frei ist und was
dies bedeutet dieser hinsicht wird ein
geistiges wesen freier sein können als
ein anderes und der höchste geist wird
sich in einer vollkommen und freiheit
befinden
während die kreaturen nicht fähig sind
also es geht nicht darum ob man tun kann
was man will
das wäre die große handlungsfreiheit
es geht darum ob der wähler selbst
unabhängigkeit sitzt also um die
struktur des finanz selbst
ob der geist frei ist ist mir noch ein
bisschen genauer schauen wir jetzt damit
meint jedenfalls ist hier ganz klar es
geht um die struktur des wollens des
willens selbst jetzt kommt ja so ein
argument wie man sich jetzt diese
willensfreiheit denken kann er sagt ich
möchte glauben dass man seine wahl
aufschieben kann und dass dies auch
recht oft geschieht besonders wenn
anderweitige gedanken überlegung
verbrechen wenn daher auch die handlung
über die man sich mit sich zu rate geht
sein oder nichtsein muss zur folgte aus
doch nicht dass man notwendigkeit deren
sein oder nichtsein beschließen müsse
wenn ihr nicht sein kann auch daher
stammen das war überhaupt kein beschluss
fasst so sprachen die europa gibson in
wirklichkeit einen mann frei dessen
prozess zu entscheiden sie zu schwierig
gefunden hatten
indem sie den prozess auf einen sehr
entfernten zeitpunkt verschoben und sich
100 jahre zu überlegung namen also was
ist jetzt hier gesagt
das ist letztendlich ein argument für
unsere willensfreiheit also wir können
uns unseren willen auf eine ganz ganz
flexible art und weise verhalten
wir müssen nicht gleich etwas nachgeben
das war so ein bisschen diese these von
john blog dass wenn wir den willen haben
dass dann die handlung einfach gleich
folgt sondern wir können auch mal den
willen erster ein bisschen aufschieben
wir haben jetzt ein willen aber ich
verhalte mich nochmal zu den villen und
ich kann mich so zu dem willen verhalten
dass ich zumindest sagen kann jetzt noch
nicht das geht immerhin ob das dann ein
wirklicher antrag willi ist der wille
den willen jetzt nicht so eine handlung
zu führen ist die andere frage aber wir
haben einen gewissen spielraum darin wie
wir mit unserem willen umgehen und das
ist schon mal so ein anzeichen dafür
dass wir über villen zweit verfügen
können nicht immer nur handlungsfreiheit
sein müssen wie es jetzt schon lockt
gedacht hatte
allerdings spricht man nur ungenau wenn
man so redet als ob wir unser wohnen
wollten
das ist die frage wieder als
willensfreiheit wollen können was man
will
wir wollen nicht wollen sondern wir
wollen handeln denn wenn wir wollen
wollten so würden wir wollen wollen
wollen und das würde bis ins unendliche
fortgehen indessen dürfen wir uns nicht
verhehlen dass wir durch freiwillige
handlungen oft indirekt andere
freiwillige handlung veranlassen können
denn obwohl man es nicht in seiner macht
hat zu wollen wie man will oder auch nur
zu urteilen wie man will so kann man
doch im voraus vorkehrungen dafür
treffen dass man sein urteil oder sein
will in der art bestimmt dass sie mit
der zeit imstande sind sich so zu
verhalten wie man es für heute von ihnen
wünschen möchte man schließt sich
menschen an man wählt eine art von
lektüre und betrachtungen die einen
fördern können man entscheidet sich für
eine bestimmte richtung ohne dass wasser
entgegen gesetzte richtung nicht zu
beachten und vermögen dieser hilfsmittel
und tausend andere die dann meistens
ohne bestimmten vorsatz und ohne daran
zu denken anwendet gelangt man dazu sich
zu ändern oder wenigstens sich zu
täuschen und sich je nach den umständen
zu bessern oder zu verschlechtern
das sagte jetzt hier wie geht es jetzt
um die frage wie wir wohnen
wir wollen nicht unseren bühnen
bestimmen können
als er sagt jetzt offensichtlich nicht
unser wollen wollen zum willen wollen
weil das so ein regress führen würde
aber was können wir dafür machen wir
können es nicht direkt machen sich
unmittelbar sondern wir können es oft
direkt tun indem wir bestimmte
vorkehrungen treffen und unsere
entscheidung in kontexte versetzen sagt
vorkehrungen vorkehrungen indem wir auf
zeit zum beispiel setzen indem wir
einfach zeit verstreichen lassen
das war das beispiel im vorherigen zitat
dass man etwas aufschiebt oder dass man
eben gewisse kontexte aufsucht bestimmte
bereiche gibt die eben uns jetzt etwas
geneigt machen als etwas anderes
hier setzt die frage natürlich die
können wir uns will endlich selbst
täuschen
also können wir uns selbst belügen so
dass wir am ende auch noch glauben aber
wir können sicherlich einfach du ich
glaube wichtigstes wirklich dass wir
sagen wir warten jetzt einfach noch wir
warten einfach
online kann so viele zwischenzeit
passieren dass unser wille bis dahin
wieder ganz anders aussieht zeigt jetzt
machen wir werden mit anderen aspekten
konfrontiert wir beziehen andere
überlegung in unserer sektion ein wir
kommen neue gründe geliefert unser
widersteht nach einiger zeit einem ganz
anderen licht dar
das ist aber jetzt nichts was nur mit
uns zusammen hängt sind wir müssen uns
dann eben der welt aussetzen so dass sie
uns neue perspektiven ermöglicht dass
unser licht in unser will in einem neuen
licht erscheint sein
und das sagt lebens das ist sehr wohl
möglich dass wir uns soeben willentlich
zu uns verhalten können dass unser
wieder nicht gleich zu einer handlung
über führen müssen dass wir beim villa
auf der ebene des willens etwas
verweilen können
aber ich glaube dass die zeit das
entscheidend ist dass wir etwas
innehalten aufschieben könnte man auch
sagen das aufschieben
ja das ist es für heute gewesen haben
sie noch fragen dazu leuchtet ihnen das
ein was bleibt es hier sagt ja
auch die streams demgegenüber die
übrigen angemacht unendlichkeit
der wille ist so verfasst dass wir nicht
im bereich der notwendigkeit liegt also
ganz wichtig ist hier noch mal die
unterscheidung zwischen tatsachen
wahrheiten und vernunft wahrheit oder
verstandes wahrheiten
das ist so der hintergrund den mann
vorläufig kennt in anderen werken
explizites ausführlicher das betrifft
diese frage nach der determination
unseres willens sind der zufälligen
wahrheiten der notwendig war also
zufällige wahrheiten hier nochmal diesem
zitat sind tatsachen wahrheit tatsachen
behalten ist sowas wie sie sagten
ich stehe jetzt auch oder dass ich eben
am soundsovielten in diesem jahr geboren
wurde ist eine tatsache bereit
aber das ist eine wahrheit die nicht
notwendig ist also diese wahrheit dass
sie alle an einem bestimmten tag zu
einer bestimmten uhrzeit geboren wurden
ist von einer anderen hart als die
wahrheit das eben cottbus fährt gleich
c-quadrat westen das ist eine andere
ebene von wahrheit das eine ihre geburt
die aussage geburt ist kontingent sie
hätte auch anders sein können sie hätten
auch an einem anderen tag geboren werden
können und die wahrheit über den
verstand die vernunft wahrheiten sind
logische wahrheiten damit der physische
ware da gibt es keine alternativen
möglichkeiten und in dieser kontingents
sieht eben leibnitz dieser tatsachen
wahrheiten dass sie eben nicht notwendig
sie darin sieht leibnitz die möglichkeit
freiheit zu denken weil für leibnitz dem
grad auch die tatsachen wahrheiten nicht
einfach nur beliebig sind sondern sie
sind determiniert aber sind nicht
notwendig ist muss man sich natürlich
genauer fragen
womit hängt das zusammen dass sie nur
determiniert sind aber nicht notwendig
man kann natürlich immer sagen ja gut
das hätte auch ganz anders sein können
wie ist denn genau dann diese
determination zu denken
diese bestimmung die nicht gleich
notwendigkeit ist also anders gefragt
wie ist in eine kontingente der
termination überhaupt denkbar
und dass sie mit der notwendigkeit
kollabiert und zusammenfällt und das ist
ein anderes wesen thema bei leibnitz und
ich will es nur kurz andeuten
da spielt jetzt verleiht uns die
unendlichkeit anzusehen müssen sich das
so vorstellen dass ich tatsachen
wahrheiten
wie ein limes also bleibt es denkt immer
die mathematik ist verleiht jetzt immer
so ein ein hintergrund seiner ganzen
überlegungen also die geometrie vor
allem oder aber auch die differenzial
rechnung sie wissen alle dass leibnitz
ungefähr zur selben zeit wie newton
diese differenzial rechnung entwickelt
hat also diese ableitung so was man ab
der elften klasse macht auf gymnasium
und die ableitung ist ja auch
letztendlich etwas was mit einem lieben
diese annäherung dieser unendlichen
annäherung zu tun hat kann das ja
herleiten diese ableitung durch so
niemals und leibnitz sagt jetzt wenn man
sich das so vorstellen dass hier ist die
sonne gerade ist die notwendigkeit und
die determination die muss man sich
vorstellen wie eine unendliche limes
artige annäherung die aber im
unendlichen erst auf diese notwendigkeit
mündet
also determination und notwendigkeit
verhalten sich so wie eben diese gerade
dass wir die notwendigkeit
und dass hier die deputation als ist nun
ein liebes eine limes artige annäherung
als die freiheit der freiheits spielraum
den leibniz jetzt in der determination
denken möchte die kontingenz die
kontingenz wird hier in diesem hohen
endlich kleinen die kleinen differenz
zur unendlichen annäherung da ist
letztendlich für leibnitz diese
kontingents der determination enthalten
im gegensatz zur notwendigkeit der
vernunft wahrheiten
ja
keine
also ich glaube dass leib riss so ein
bisschen konsequenter ist bei kane ist
alles ein bisschen beliebig so erscheint
mir dieser spielraum ja wie groß muss
ist der spielraum sein und so weiter und
bleiben es gibt hier einfach so eine
mathematische funktionen ist einfach
mathematisches alte liebe ist wie mies
drauf wenn wir können es gar nicht
messen
deshalb geht es unendliche also der clou
ist einfach vielleicht sagen mit der
unendlichkeit der unendlichkeit struktur
von tatsachen wahrheiten also er sagt
alle tatsachen wahrheiten verhalten sich
zu den vernunft wahrheiten sowie der
limes unendliche annäherung zu dieser
geraten
in dieser unendlichen unendlichen
struktur da liegt gerade die freiheit
bekommt das ist jetzt natürlich erst mal
nur eine veranschaulichung aber kann das
noch ein bisschen genauer beschreiben
ich kann das in der zusammenfassung noch
ein bisschen weiter exportieren leiten
sagt jedenfalls es gibt eben zwei
mysterien in der philosophie die zwei
größten fragen und die betreffen die
freiheit um die unendlichkeit das sind
die zwei größten labyrinthe unseres
geistes die freiheit und die
unendlichkeit und auch das kontinuum
solche solche fragen also genau genommen
sagte das continium also wie wir etwas
als kontinuierlich sehen können wie so
eine gerade mit unendlich vielen punkten
und die freiheit und die sind die großen
mysterien und die antwort auf diese
frage
freiheit und continuum gelegt in der
unendlichkeit wenn sie mit dem begriff
der unendlichkeit können wir das alles
erklären das ist jedenfalls seine
antwort auf die frage wie wir jetzt der
terminiert sein können ohne genötigt zu
werden und das ist eben dieser kleine
unendliche spielraum des limes vom hin
zum zu geraten
gar keine freiheiten
das ist leibnitz angebot zu sehen er hat
die mathematik sich hier als ein vorbild
genommen die für vieles und das ist
jetzt auch zusammengefasst so die
antwort auf an john lockt also leibnitz
sagt wir können uns sehr wohl einen
freien willen denken indem wir ihnen von
der notwendigkeit unterscheiden
dann ist zur nächsten sitzung in der wir
uns mit immanuel kant beschäftigen
werden und der frage wie man freiheit
und determination insbesondere natur
gesetzlichkeit zusammen denken kann
bis dann